Le réseau téléphonique de Michel nous a été amené là-bas
et emmené dans plusieurs endroits que
nous connaissons bien, je ne sais pas
vraiment grand-chose, à part ça,
nous avons vu quelques photos des
scènes et nous reconnaissons les endroits, je
pense que ces endroits  il y en avait deux ou
trois dans le centre de Hacer dont il
semble qu'il a rencontré Joanna, l'un
était à la gare routière, l'autre à la poste et il
y avait des recherches vers d'autres endroits
également, nous avons reconnu qu'il y avait aussi
bien sûr l'emplacement à Monaco par le
rivière où le corps de Joe a été retrouvé,
nous connaissons donc assez bien ces endroits,
qu'est-ce que cela signifiait pour vous de voir la faune
à ces endroits, eh bien, c'était
assez émouvant, évidemment, nous avons vu
les lieux et des photographies d'eux
plusieurs fois au cours du  années mais
voir fawni taux il y avait alors évidemment
une dimension supplémentaire et ça m'a rappelé
beaucoup de souvenirs je veux dire je ne sais pas trop exactement
ce que les autorités françaises
espéraient tirer de cette reconstruction pour
être honnête on sait déjà que
les étrangers ont avoué  Le meurtre de Joe et
Olivia ont également confirmé ces aveux,
mais nous considérons néanmoins cela
comme une étape positive et nous attendrons simplement
de connaître les répercussions.
Je pense que c'est probablement la seule
chose que nous pourrons probablement
pour en sortir, il est peut-être
possible que cela ait
rafraîchi la mémoire de Fournier, peut-être parce
qu'à notre connaissance, il n'a pas donné
de détails réels sur ce qui
s'est passé entre lui et Joe, il se peut donc
que ce soit un exercice pour  pour
le provoquer et en rapporter
certaines informations dont
on sait bien sûr qu'il a été
responsable de beaucoup de meurtres tragiquement
et on sait aussi par d'autres cas qu'il y a
déjà eu des coupables
qu'il confond ces affaires il confond
les informations donc  il se peut que cela
lui ait en quelque sorte éclairci l'esprit et c'est
également important en raison du fait que
cela est lié aux cas de Joe. Marie a
apprécié le désordre oui d'accord oui oui
c'est vrai ouais oui nous sommes au courant de
cette affaire et ce depuis un certain temps
Bien sûr, le corps de Mary Angela n'a jamais
été retrouvé et c'est l'une des choses
que nous espérons pouvoir résulter de ce
récent voyage vers la Terre.